der Überfall auf die Ukraine verläuft
für die russische Armee ganz anders als
geplant statt schneller Erfolge immense
Verluste mit den militärischen
Rückschlägen wird lange unterdrückte
Kritik an der Militärführung laut unter
anderem von extrem nationalistischen
Kommentatoren und Bloggern aber auch in
Putins Umfeld zum Beispiel von Jewgeni
priore der 61-Jährige Unternehmer auch
Putins Koch genannt ist Gründer der
Söldnergruppe Wagner der immer wieder
Verstöße gegen die Menschenrechte
vorgeworfen wird prigorce Truppe
versucht sich auch in der Ostukraine
Erfolge zu erkämpfen rigor in selbst
kritisierte zuletzt
Verteidigungsminister Sergey Buch
kritik kommt auch von dem
tschetschenischen Staatschef Ramsan
kadirov er gilt als Putins Bluthund und
soll besonders skrupellos sein der Ruf
seiner Kämpfer soll auch in der Ukraine
Angst und Schrecken verbreiten
ausgerechnet kadirov wurde im Oktober
von Putin zum generalobers befördert
eine ins Ausland geflohene FSB
Mitarbeiterin berichtet im Oktober dass
der Inlandsgeheimdienst in prigotten und
kadirov die größte Gefahr für Putins
macht sieht